on a tout de suite décryptage et analyse
on va plus loin
[Musique]
et on va plus loin avec à mes côtés
marie roger biloa comme chaque mardi
directrice du groupe afrique
international bonjour marie roja face à
vous bilal tarabella rédaction de france
24 bonjour bilal bonjour raphaël les
différents groupes d'experts nations
unis en tête ont déjà largement sonné l
alerte sur le climat corollaire du
réchauffement le désert avance
inexorablement sur la planète près de la
moitié des terres 40% d'après l'onu sont
aujourd'hui dégradé c'est encore plus
vrai en afrique où la bande sahélienne
n'a jamais aussi bien porté son nom de
zone désertique raison pour laquelle dix
chefs d'état de la région sont réunis à
abidjan une cop15 contre la
désertification
écoutez alassane ouattara la nouvelle
fiction la sécheresse sans source de
migrations et le conflit inter
communautaire
en raison de la compétition au tour des
ressources naturelles en constante
diminution
dans ces conditions il est essentiel
d'adopter des politiques qui soutiennent
la résilience les populations notamment
les plus vulnérables
c'est ça la véritable urgence
environnementale aujourd'hui marie roger
lutter contre la désertification
je crois que tout l'argent et et pour
l'afrique là c'est sûr elle c'est
particulier elle frappe oui sauf que
l'on a vu des massacres même pour
l'accélérateur exactement dans le mali
par exemple mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est que les questions
environnementales
ne sont pas
comment dire sans lien avec le reste
c'est à dire on va là on parlait de ce
que tellement terre de ces de sécurité
tout court dans le sahel mais aussi les
problèmes économiques cdse des problèmes
sociaux donc actuellement ce qui est
assez frappant lorsqu'on écoute c'est
quand même le tableau d'horreur tous
ceux qui se sont succédé sur le plateau
là bas on dressait de notre planète un
tableau absolument apocalyptique et ça
fait un moment que ça dure est
intéressant aussi c'est que ça ça
résonne après la campagne électorale
qu'on a eu en france
et qui a forcé le président macro à
mettre
la question de l'environnement le climat
l'écologie vraiment au centre de son
prochain quelqu'un qui nous verra qui
sera le visage choisi pour le portait
d'ailleurs heureusement c'est un souci
et la côte d'ivoire comme pays est assez
emblématique parce que elle a perdu
depuis
lundi les indépendants de 60 ans
80% de son couvert forestier c'est
absolument ahurissant et lorsqu'il
actuellement le projet comme on l'a
entendu là-bas c'était de de reboiser en
fait de deux de remédier à ça et de
comment ce qu'il a eu 10 et il voulait
restaurer 3 millions d'hectares en huit
ans c'est quand même un peu vous semble
utopique c'est il ya beaucoup d'utopie
mais je sais une chose c'est que le
projet intéressant et qui regroupe tout
ce qu'on vient de dire c'est à dire que
l'écologie c'est un peu tous et
l'économie c'est celle à venir c'est
tout ce projet de grande muraille barque
verte si je crois qu'on peut en parler à
l'évoquer dans un instant
désertification ce mot un bilel tarabet
et on imagine bien à quoi il fait
référence mais en fait ils recouvrent
des réalités à très concrètes pour non
pas des millions et des milliards comme
l'a dit emmanuel macron aujourd'hui
d'être d'êtres humains des manuels macro
aujourd'hui dans le message un qui
l'envoya la cop15 a dit précisément 3,2
milliards d'êtres humains sur terre
alors l'onu aussi à faire rapport là
qu'il a publié en avril les zones arides
représente 45 % de la surface de la
terre c'est quasiment la moitié de la
surface terrestre dans lesquelles vivent
un être humain sur trois donc c'est
absolument pas négligeable et vous le
disiez ça couvre des réalités très
différentes puisque la répartition
géographique
eh bien elle est quasiment partout où je
vais juste vous donner quelques chiffres
un peu plus précis 73% des zones arides
se trouvent en afrique 33% en asie 14%
en australie mais on a une grande zone
une longue bande d'aridité qui va de la
patagonie au sud de la mer du sud jusque
quasiment l'alaska et qui coupent si
vous voulez tout l'ouest du continent
américain nord et sud l'europe n'est pas
épargnée puisque l'espagne elle aussi
elle est touchée alors concrètement
quand on parle de désertification on
parle de quoi on parle d'une
raréfication des pluies qui entraîne de
la sécheresse qui entraîne donc moindres
écoles - de récolte moins de bétail et
donc des phénomènes d'insécurité
alimentaire aiguë et de famine oui moins
de laisser la sécurité alimentaire dans
un contexte on s'est aussi
particulièrement tendue puisque une
partie de l'europe en tout cas son flanc
oriental aujourd'hui est en guerre et
notamment deux pays qui sont les
principaux grenier à blé indue du marché
mondial que sont la russie et l'ukraine
cela ajoute encore un stress comme on
dit on mais bien su la scion est même
actuellement la france aussi est sous
alerte de sécheresse il ya plusieurs
villes qui sont qui ont été signalés
dont c'est pas des questions qui sont
éloignées ni de l'afrique ni de la
france ni de personne c'est vraiment des
questions d'actualité et tout est de
savoir si toutes ces impulsions qu'on
donne finalement après les coop et serra
ont fait les bilans on est toujours très
déçu mais il
parlait de continuer à mettre cette
question au premier plan c'est la seule
façon d'espérer qu'un jour il y aura des
résultats quand on voit la difficulté
des pays développés à ne serait-ce que à
s'attaquer au problème du dérèglement
climatique de réduire leurs émissions de
co2 on voit qu'aujourd'hui encore on en
est loin vous pensez réellement qu'ils
pourront demain participer à l'effort
collectif dans la lutte contre la
désertification qui concerne
majoritairement malgré tout des pays
dits en développement alors ce qui est
intéressant c'est que les pays africains
prennent conscience de manière un peu
plus sérieuse des questions
environnementales et climatiques
vous avez des gens qui vous disent
comme j'ai vu dernièrement un
agriculteur qui à peu près 80 ans qui
n'a fait que ça toute sa vie et vous dit
ça fait depuis que je cultive la terre
c'est la première fois que je vois les
les saisons qui sont complètement
déglingué complètement et pleut comme
s'y attend pas et on a laissé sur elle
s'est dite des stress hydriques à des
moments aussi totalement imprévue donc
ça ça se voit les gens en parlent ce
n'est plus quelque chose de facultatif
et la la la la côte d'ivoire et j'allais
conférence est actuellement en font
quand même un problème global c'est à
dire et lorsqu'on parle justement
j'aimerais
grand départ 11 ans de cette muraille 1
qui concerne donc un qui s'étendrait de
du sénégalais jusqu'à djibouti ouais on
parle d'un projet à horizon 2030 100
millions d'hectares de terres lorsqu'on
voit la difficulté qu'ont aujourd'hui à
sa tombe depuis à cohabiter et partager
des ressources
prenons l'exemple par exemple du fleuve
le nil partagé entre les gilts le soudan
les audi quand on voit la difficulté
aujourd'hui qu'ont ces pays à 100 tant
les conflits même que créer
l'exploitation de ce fleuve est ce qu'on
peut parvenir à mettre en oeuvre des
projets panafricain environnementaux
lorsqu'on commence à un projet comme ça
ça peut pas être exempt de conflits ce
qu'ils peuvent compter qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire à l'intérieur de de toute la
liste du programme parce que c'est un
programme secret le vertueux même pas
contrairement ce que les gens ont cru
c'est pas il s'agit pas juste euros
boisé de planter des arbres c'est c'est
un programme qui concerne les sols la
restauration des sols qui concerne de
nouvelles pratiques agricoles les
espèces plus approprié et qui concerne
la sécurité alimentaire est un problème
économique qui permettrait aux gens dans
leur localité de rester là et de et de
pouvoir vivre sur place donc à partir de
ce moment-là il y à pas mal de choses à
faire avant d'arriver au conflit comment
n'y a pas de conflits partout déjà si on
pouvait déjà régler un certain nombre de
problèmes
déjà avancé la mise en valeur des sols
ça peut être un en tout cas un objectif
partagé de tous et
pour le moment c'est pas théorique parce
qu'au bout de dix quinze ans l'onu
estime qu'on a on l'a fait à peu près à
10-15 %
c'est déjà un début bilal tardi ont
évoqué les investissements nécessaires
alassane ouattara réclame pas enfin pas
tout cas estime un pour son plan
initiative abidjan qu'il faudra
mobiliser un milliard et demi de dollars
sur cinq ans c'est la condition pour
justement permettre de reboiser en
partition son pays vous l'avez dit marie
roger l'art très durement touché 1 par
la déforestation on sait bien cette
désertification à hilla conséquence pas
seulement bien sûr mais entre autres
aussi de notre activité industrielle ça
pour aussi le bien d'autres problèmes
demain à travers les mouvements de
population il faut en prendre conscience
et ce qu'on en a conscience d'ailleurs
écouter alors oui nous
alors à travers les mouvements de
population il y en a déjà est-ce que ça
va concerner les pays occidentaux en
fait oui mais pas tellement sur cet
aspect là je m'explique on a les
chiffres des mouvements de population
dans le monde par année il y a li mdc
qui est donc le principal organisme qui
est chargé de savon etc il ya entre 20
et 40 millions de réfugiés par an c'est
à dire de gens qui se déplacent de leur
domicile vers quelque part ailleurs par
an les assurés nés en revanche la voilà
et mais alors ce qui est ce qui est
intéressant il sait il ce je pense que
ça remet en cause une idée reçue qu'on a
nous ici en occident c'est que la
proportion entre les gens qui se
déplacent si vous voulez à cause des
guerres et des conflits est beaucoup
plus faible que la proportion de gens
qui se déplacent à cause de catastrophes
naturelles dont 80% 95% soit créée par
les changements climatiques et tout ça
c'est pas du verbiage puisqu'on a des
chiffres il y avait en 2020
33,4 millions de réfugiés dans le monde
sur ces 33,4 il y en avait et 8,5 qui se
sont déplacés à cause de guerre ou de
conflit et 24,9 à cause de deux cadeaux
trois fois plus cher exactement de trois
fois plus
donc ce qu'il faut savoir en revanche
c'est que 20 % des gens qui migrent 20%
des réfugiés ne quittent pas leur région
d'origine si vous voulez donc ce qui va
se passer ce qui se passe d'ailleurs
déjà et on le voit en afrique
concentration sur les terres cultivables
exactement soit des concentrations sur
les cadres terres cultivables c'est à
dire qu'on va dans la vallée d'un côté
là où c'est un petit peu mieux soin et
ça c'est ce qu'on voit et marie roger
biloa le sait très bien c'est la
surpopulation des capitales africaines
qui voit arriver des dizaines de
milliers des centaines de milliers de
jeunes des zones rurales pour venir
chercher du travail et qui en fait
malheureusement trop souvent grossistes
les bidonvilles et ça en fait si vous
voulez pourquoi ça nous concerne c'est
parce que finalement on va avoir
énormément de pays du sud comme on les
appelle donc en afrique ou en asie du
sud-est dont finalement les structures
sociétales ou politiques seront
déstabilisés à cause de ses mouvements
et c'est là que ça arrive si vous voulez
de concerner le monde plus généralement
plus que des mouvements de population
individuelle des transits direct 1 vous
vouliez ajouté on va passer peut-être à
notre sujet un monde jésus ce projet de
grande muraille eurogroupe tout ça parce
que il a reçu aussi le soutien de ce one
somites planète là l'an dernier qui le
reconnaît comme un projet phare qui est
assez inédit il n'y a pas un autre
projet de la même ampleur sur toute la
planète et donc ce qu'est un projet
qu'il faut absolument soutenir le projet
de grande muraille verte de dakar du
sénégal à djibouti jusqu'à djibouti se
dit mais c'est aussi la journée
nationale des mémoires de la traite de
l'esclavagé et de leurs abolitions ici
en france une journée a institué en 2006
emmanuel macron à présider pour
l'occasion une cérémonie au jardin du
luxembourg aujourd'hui à paris ouverte
par la chanteuse réunionnaise christine
salem c'est important marie roger biloa
de garder vivace le souvenir de la
traite est aussi un de se souvenir à
cette occasion que c'est une loi ici en
france la loi taubira qui reconnaît
cette traite et l'esclavagé comme crime
contre l'humanité oui c'est des lois est
absolument exceptionnel et
je crois qu'elle a commencé à contribuer
à réconcilier un petit peu l'état
français avec les populations des pays
qui ont connu de l'esclavagé mais
aujourd'hui il ya un problème si on a vu
les images dit mais n'avait pas grand
monde parce que c'est bien une date qui
est controversée
donc
les antillais l'écart et biya les
guyanais même les africains qui suivent
tout ça bon écoute un peu parce que la
date choisie avait été le 23 le 23 mai
et pourquoi il ya une différence est ce
que l'état français a bien voté la loi
en disant on va comment commémorer la
mémoire de l'esclavagé au 23 mai au
lendemain parce que c'est la date qui a
été proposée par un comité le comité de
la marche de 1998 qui avait réuni 4 48
personnes dans les rues de paris en
demandant sa jument que nous voulons
lier une date ce serait le 23 parce que
c'est la date place de qui la date des
souffrances enfin de la mémoire des
souffrances et des victimes alors que le
10 mai c'est la date un peu qui la date
d abolition est aussi de la loi taubira
donc l'état préfère regarder la question
de cavale sous le prisme de l'abolition
et des progrès qui ont été faits n'est
ce pas plutôt que de la zone étudiée à
l'état plutôt que j'ai penché sur le
suivant à la vie donc il ya un vrai un
vrai souci là et il y a parmi les choses
qui ont été demandés aussi cia un
mémorial des noms aux tuileries tout ça
a été accordé mais maintenant l'état
traîne des pieds donc il ya des
communiqués qui sont sortis aussi
aujourd'hui des des activistes de
martinique et de guadeloupe pour dire
voilà les élections ont envoyé un
message à l'état renonçait il faudrait
s'intéresser de plus près à ces
questions une pratique qui n'a pas
disparu loin de là elles perdurent
notamment dans certains pays du proche
orient avec le système de la kafala
expliquez-nous à bilal tarbes et vous
qui avez couvert ce phénomène dans les
pays qui le pratique mais aussi ceux
dont sont originaires les victimes de
cette forme d'exploitation modernes
oui parce que pendant à peu près 7 8 ans
si vous voulez j'ai vécu à may hamm j'ai
travaillé comme correspondant alors pour
ce groupe à madagascar et au liban donc
madagascar d'où partent des femmes pour
devenir domestique alors là je vais
mettre des guinness pas grave le sujet
le sujet l'admet si vous voulez qu'ils
partent sphère domestique au
moyen-orient donc parmi les pays où
elles partent le liban d'où elles
reviennent effectivement donc au liban
pays où elle travaille voilà là aussi je
mets des guillemets de quoi on parle ici
on parle je vais vraiment prendre cet
exemple pour que ce soit clair pour tout
le monde on parle d'un pays madagascar
en l'occurrence où le salaire mensuel
est à peu près de 40 dollars par mois là
on a des gens qui vivent dans un pays où
la domesticité si vous voulez se
pratique déjà parce que c'est quelque
chose de culturel qui se disent bon
quitte à gagner un peu d'argent en étant
domestique autant aller là où on propose
100 fois plus c'est à dire le proche
moyen-orient ou typiquement au liban je
vais gagner non pas 45 dollars mais 250
dollars dont qu'elle parte sur cette
promesse là sauf qu'elle arrivait elle
arrive dans ce système vous l'avez dit
qui s'appelle la kafala la kafala c'est
quoi c'est en fait un parrainage ont
parraine un grand qui vient qui a été
dévoyé en devenant une mise sous tutelle
qui elle même est devenue de l'esclave
alors la confiscation des papiers en
gros la confiscation des pato on en
garde sa liberté de mouvement ou
entravent ses libertés de mouvements
isolement physique isolement
psychologique je vais vous donner
simplement un chiffre qui vient des
autorités libanaises elle-même en 2020
il y avait deux domestiques qui mourait
au liban chaque semaine la plupart du
temps les cas étaient considérés comme
étant des suicides ce qui est déjà bien
assez grave comme ça mais très
fréquemment il y à des accusations si
vous voulez de deux meurtres pour
simplement une idée voilà ya encore
aujourd'hui à peu près de 250000
domestiques étrangères au liban qui pour
l'immense écrasante majorité 99 %
d'entre elles viennent soit d'asie du
sud est soit de la corne de l'afrique ou
de l'afrique subsaharienne et plus
généralement parce que c'est quand même
sidérant on en parle aujourd'hui
l'esclavagé moderne on a les chiffres
concernent si vous voulez 45,1 millions
de personnes dans le monde parce qu'on
parle de ce travail forcé dont relève la
kafala mais il faut aussi parler de la
servitude pour dettes qui concerne les
migrants qui bien souvent doivent
rembourser toute leur vie et avec leurs
enfants les voyages vont leur avait
accordé et il y à la traite d'êtres
humains les réseaux de prostitution de
travail forcé etc et c'est un mot très
rapide il faut qu'on termine maintenant
mais je vous dis réagissent à la traite
orientale parce que lendemain de la
grande déportation elle traite
transatlantique mais la traite orientale
a été au moins aussi importante et là
bas il n'y a pas eu de et elle perdure
reconnaissance de reconnaissance uni de
d'autorisation ou même et c'est pour ça
que là bas dans les pays arabes souvent
les noirs sont configurés continue
d'être considérés comme des êtres
inférieurs
merci marie roger merci à bilal
tarabella témoignages de journalistes
aussi et de son passé de correspondants
pour france 24 c'est la fin de ce
journal rester avec nous on se retrouve
dans moins de deux minutes pour une
nouvelle édition
[Musique]